dolcetto o scherzetto si sta avvicinando
Halloween quindi non possiamo non
giocare a un nuovo gioco di Halloween
Tra l'altro i giochi paurosi sono quelli
che ci richiedete sempre più spesso
quindi
Mettetevi comodi prendete i Popcorn e
iniziamo questa nuova avventura assieme
Eccoci qua il cattivo di oggi è questo
pagliaccio cattivo vediamo che cosa ci
aspetta Eccoci ho sentito che questa
casa infestata è spaventosa Ehi lascia
giocare la verità eh oh oh In che senso
aiuto Ti sfido ad entrare Quindi inizia
lui e ci sfida ad entrare ma noi
entriamo noi non abbiamo mica paura Oh
guarda ci sono delle ossa scriveteci nei
commenti che cosa vi fa più paura che
tipo di mostro vi fa più paura Vitale
sei già sfracellato visto che fa più
paura a Vitale sono queste ossa giganti
Allora noi cosa fa più paura Allora te
cosa fanno più paura i fantasmi
scheletri morti
mi fanno molta avere paura ma i fantasmi
non puoi vederli proprio perché non li
puoi vedere che fanno paura a me invece
fanno più paura i mostri mostri Sì
Soprattutto quelli che sembrano tipo
degli insetti o tipo il dermagorje sì
quelli mi fanno più paura a voi Qual è
il personaggio di Halloween che fa più
paura scrivetelo nei commenti ma siamo
arrivate tu una casa
stregata Eccola la televisione tra Anita
e vitale
va bene Lo ammetto sono un po'
spaventato credo che dobbiamo saltare
sopra queste zucche via via andiamo
sopra le zucche Eh ho paura che caschi
Uh uh uh la mia festa preferita Io adoro
le zucche di Halloween
non solo di Halloween ma in generale tu
la dovrei mangiare le zucche qualsiasi
altra cosa Dai che sono in vantaggio Dai
che sono in vantaggio Uh Uh aspetta
queste ossa cadono sei caduta ah ah
arriverà prima a vincerà la Challenge
cominciare tutto da capo qui da queste
ossa e io non capisco dove devo andare
qua sopra questi occhi forse uh
sto camminando su degli occhi giganti
Wow
vediamo se si srascella no Tanto io che
sono comunque in vantaggio
nella stessa punto ci siamo sfracellati
di nuovo riproviamo
Allora bisogna stare molto attenti qui
eh E soprattutto chi sta ah ah avanti
e non ci
posso credere anch'io i ragni giganti
fanno parte di Halloween Okay Okay
Allora era i giganti dei morti
giganti a te Fanno più paura i fantasmi
dei ragni giganti Assolutamente sì a voi
cosa verrebbe più paura un fantasma un
ragno gigante No matti non sei d'accordo
con Anita
perché mi sono sfracellata però cioè è
solo un tappeto sono già due stage
avanti via via via via Come non detto
sono flagellato Infatti non ti vedo più
Ah no ma io sono già avanti io sono il
prossimo no
questa casa stregata è bellissima Io
adoro le case stregate questi che che
cosa sarebbero delle solite cosa c'è
ho capito
scusami ho capito questi lenzuoli
servono a scappare cioè come nei film
Avete presente dei film quando provano
anche Campari
nelle regioni in generale lega un
lenzuolo fanno i nodi e poi si cadono
giù dalla finestra voi non lo fate Mi
raccomando perché comunque è
pericolosissimo
Infatti vedevo andare capito
è un mostro un bambino diciamo
Oh interessante Non vedo l'ora di vedere
che cos'è vediamo Siamo in un cimitero
subito
ti buttati morbido via
Wow figo è bellissimo che c'è scritto
bene dice salta sulle mie spalle poi usa
le lapidi per attraversarle Okay Sì
certo È normale saltare sulle lapidi per
passare da una parte all'altra bisogna
spregelato Non ci posso credere
Oppure sei già al cimitero Quindi puoi
anche rimanere lì Vabbè effettivamente
Guarda cosa ci aspetta e ho visto un
portale dentro la bocca
Hai sbagliato
No
ok ok Oh vabbè perché il protagonista di
questa Escape Room era il pagliaccio
quindi è ovvio che dovremo probabilmente
affrontare un pagliaccio adesso Niente
dobbiamo raccogliere 500 caramelle tutte
tutte per fare dovevo prendere io Ah ah
ah dobbiamo fare dolcetto o scherzetto
Oh figo eh dolcetto o scherzetto Ehi ma
mi ha dato niente eh mi ha dato soltanto
caramelle Oh me ha dato 76 caramelle Dai
oh io ho 78 di più a casa gli scherzetti
a Vitale no Ehi Lasciami un po' di
caramelle per favore
o 160 caramelle sbrighiamoci dobbiamo
prendere più caramelle di Vitale che tra
l'altro potrebbe mangiarle tutte
258 non entrare nelle case qui
non entro io no no sono poche caramelle
poi soprattutto con me
Fabio 353 tu 33 okay
Mi porterò più caramelle forse vediamo
Ho suonato il campanello Ehi Quanto ci
mettete da aprire Wow 420 44
Vitale ha già svuotato questa casa di
caramelle Evviva obiettivo
498 raga Sono uno si è sbloccato un
nuovo funzionario tipo si è sbloccato
qualcosa Eh sei col pagliaccio non
ancora lo vedi Wow i cancelli si sono
verdi che cosa ci aspetteranno adesso
dai qualcosa no
forse forse sono aperti questi cancelli
forse li dobbiamo cercare qui vediamo no
credo che dobbiamo Sì c'è l'uomo zucca
che ci aspetta davvero Eccolo qua Eccolo
qua
raccogli 500 caramelle
Ciao
labirinto Wow Oddio Vitale no sono
proprio qui dietro di te ok il tuo punto
debole del labirinto Quindi io me ne
vado ciao ciao
no non copiarvi
qua non c'è via d'uscita vediamo qua
Comunque penso che sì sì sì ci siamo
riusciti nella zucca chi è questo
la zucca
adesso dove andiamo dentro una zucca
Brava
No cioè non sapevo questa cosa però non
sappiamo che il Roblox magari dovrebbe
avere dei semi al posto delle ossa è
come quando il Roblox ci mangiano e poi
hanno mangiato tipo le lattine intere
senza essere masticate Ehi dove sei Mi
sono sfracellato sono avanti Ormai tutti
Ho battuto tantissimo
brava ce l'ho fatta io mi sono sfondato
due volte lì
sarà più veloce sono più avanti
o la mano del pagliaccio Inizia ad
essere sempre più difficile
dai Voglio vedere il lavoro che prendete
Uffa
c'è un'altra mano questa mano potrebbe
prendere in Italia vediamo ma oh oh oh
oh
è difficilissimo Quindi non sei stato
preso dalla mano del pagliaccio
velocissimo
aspetta a quanto pare non siamo usciti
dopo la parte lì della Zucca perché sono
già fuori sulla strada quindi
Beh la zucca non ha quella parte lì
sapete di cosa c'è dentro
Dai sbrigati ancora sulle caramelle Uffa
via Dai dai dai sono qui eccoti Eccoti
Dai Dai siamo tornati nella strada
uscita usciamo da qui usciamo Uh Che
cos'è Sarebbero questi tentacoli No
forse sono le radici della Zucca
erano le sfide così grandi
Uhm Forse bisogna stare attenti a questa
caramella eh Qualcosa mi dice che siamo
vicini al Batch Non devo assolutamente
niente
Dov'è il Belgio
forse dobbiamo prendere una di queste
faccine che è successo perché ho
cambiato faccia così e io No che brutta
brutta
ragazzi credo che il Belgio è andato in
automatico Cioè credo in automatico Ma
secondo queste Escape Room è stata molto
facile proviamo una nuova Escape Room di
Halloween Benvenuto nel tutorial
Cominciamo dalle basi Ok questa è una
casa sali su nelle campanello facendo
clic per rivelare un trucco una sorpresa
che sarebbe dolcetto scherzetto Ma
l'hanno tradotto male il Trick or Treat
Okay okay quindi dobbiamo fare questo
scherzetto fighissimo se ricevi un
trucco cioè
scherzetto Esatto
le caramelle vengono gettate
cibo
sulle caramelle per raggiungere la tua
borsa questo rappresenta la tua
caramella il primo numero è la caramella
che hai al secondo e la caramella
Massimo che la tua borsa equipaggia può
contenere ok 0.25 Questo rappresenta il
tuo denaro guadagni denaro scambiando le
tue caramelle Nelle stazioni di Candy
Exchange ma comunque dando le missioni
Questa è una stazione di scambio
caramelle Fai clic per scambiare le
caramelle puoi anche comprarne alcune Ok
figo
Questo è un personaggio parla con loro
per conoscere le informazioni sulla
missione con musica
Questo è il tuo registro delle missioni
per vedere il progresso ok Questo è il
tuo inventario Questa è la Mini mappa
molto questi sono i negozi dove puoi
comprare borse e costumi animali Ok
Iniziamo a fare il dolcetto scherzetto
Allora io vedo in questa casa Già Tu
invece eh ma non so dove sei andiamo
insieme
tu mi vedi io sono allo scambio di
caramelle
Eccoti forse ti vedo andiamo a fare
dolcetto scherzetto a questa casa allora
suoniamo il campanello Caramelle
non scherzetto Ciao Prendi alcuni pezzi
di caramelle Eh ma solo una sei un po'
un po' tirchio Allora c'era qualcun
altro dai Io ho preso quattro caramelle
vediamo che riuscirà a prendere più
tempo
mi ero fermato mi ero fermato a parlare
con Jack O'Lantern che mi ha dato una
missione Ah devo scolpire 20 zuccheri
per alleggerire l'originale per
alleggerire il vicinato eh alleggerire
il vicinato
Che paura e poi è quello che fa più
paura a te Sì Uffa solo 4 caramelle tu
zero zero ancora non sono riuscito a
prenderla neanche una
aiuto aiuto aiuto
quando escono gli scherzetti cioè i
mostri bisogna spostarsi l'ho preso solo
uno due tre quattro Quante sono sono tre
Ehi perché le mie caramelle sono
diventate zero perché non sei riuscito
mica a prenderle così ne ho preso
quattro devo dire che se ti prendono i
mostri ti tolgono le caramelle
che io sono in vantaggio Ciao Vediamo Ah
meno male non era un mostro perché tu
quante caramelle hai niente contro tre
Vabbè con delle caramelle Beh
giustamente questa signora ha detto che
dovevo mettermi il costume di Halloween
costume da unicorno qua non c'entra
niente Io sono a 7 caramelle io 4
Ehi ciao dolcetto scherzetto Dai devo
superare in ritardo dolcetto scherzetto
questa mi raccomando le caramelle non le
devi mangiare le devi collezionare per
poi scambiarli con qualcosa nei miei
negozi
mi ha dato un sacco di caramelle Mmm che
bello dimmi qual è la casa così prova
anche io ve lo dico Ehi Che cos'è questo
c'è un negozio con una busta sopra
No io sono morta di nuovo
Ecco Vitale Adesso andremo insieme a
fare dolcetto scherzetto così non mi
sfracello solo io ma si sfracella anche
lui così ti rubo tutte le caramelle Dai
che cazzo andiamo
che c'è qua io ho già preso due missioni
ma non so Wow ci sono i maghi Wow È
bellissimo questo gioco si può comprare
una scopa volante eh
costume andiamo a prendere un costume
con 13 caramelle ce la farò No secondo
me costano molto di più vediamo
Allora andiamo a vendere un po' di
caramelle Ok tu non ce li hai ah ah
E tu quante ne avresti 13 Dove si
cambiano e penso che prima dobbiamo
prendere un bel po' più di caramelle gli
animali vediamo Che animali ci sono
delle zucche eh eh animali
ci sono dei cuccioli di fantasma i
draghi
gattini fantasmi Voglio il gattino
fantasma assolutamente Dimmi subito
Quanto costa
Dov'è Eccolo non ci credo ci sono c'è
anche la Vespa la Vespa il monopattino e
la moto
eravamo al negozio di animali sono
andato qui Guardami sono qui Eccomi Ciao
ciao
ancora nel negozio Sì tu sei scappato
nel frattempo la caverna dei cristalli
Wow ci sono veramente un sacco di cose
da poter comprare qua è fighissimo
poveri quindi dobbiamo continuare a fare
dolcetto o scherzetto Aspetta Qua non ci
sono case Dove stai andando tappo di
zucca Eh Credo che sia Dove dove ci sono
le zucche dove coltivano le zucche Ah il
campo di zucchero infatti ce ne sono
tantissime cose belle si possono
prendere Mmm cosa c'è qua parliamo con
Lo spaventapasseri che dice Ehi hai un
secondo aiuto uno spaventapasseri
ragazzi sono stati rubati dai corpi
quando Poverino sono volati via con loro
ho bisogno di entrambi gli arti e
dobbiamo trovarli e poi ci sarà una
ricompensa di 60
Wow accettiamo la missione Però come
facciamo ora a trovare queste cose pian
piano eh Eccolo lo vedi qua oh oh oh Vai
via che faccio dammi subito
il braccio avanti no non ce l'ha questo
però adesso sono stati gli altri colpi a
prenderlo comunque prima Vabbè stavo
facendo un'altra missione Effettivamente
ho trovato Oh Forse ho trovato qualcosa
comprato una scopa rosa però bisogna
fare la missione Io prima ho trovato dei
pezzi di zucca che stavo prendendo per
un'altra missione Ma non l'hai
completata ovviamente quindi questo
gioco È pieno di missioni da fare un
pieno di ricompense già mi piace
tantissimo e voi lasciate un bel mi
piace perché se questo video raggiunge i
5000 mi piace faremo anche una seconda
parte con questo gioco con cui proviamo
a completare più opzioni possibili ma
ora proviamo a recuperare un po' di
caramelle per qualcosa Cosa c'è Oh che
bello qua dice di parlare con il signor
fungo eh eh aiuto Questi elementi hanno
rubato la nostra casa
E che cosa Mettili a dormire così
possiamo riprendere la nostra casa Ok
accettiamo anche la missione di Mr gurgo
Io ho trovato Angela che in realtà era
tipo un drago
era un dinosauro non ho capito che
cos'era aiuto cosa devo fare Ah devo
farli addormentare queste sorta di robot
e viene ad aiutarvi con attenzione un
attimo sto scambiando le caramelle per
dei soldi così posso comprarmi questo
dov'è ah ah quanto ti danno per una
caramella Allora se vendo 10 caramelle
vediamo seleziono tutto 13 caramelle
equivalgono a 6,50 di soldi
troppo poche quindi conviene prendere
più caramelle
Io sto completando la mia prima missione
sto facendo addormentare questa sorta di
robot così poi Mister fungo mi darà la
ricompensa
Meno male non mi attaccano che è
addormentato ne mancava solo
addormentare 7 quindi comunque questo
posto è bellissimo cioè questa volta è
molto grande
non solo raccogliere caramelle ma farà
anche le missioni secondarie Sì l'ultimo
Vediamo cosa succede Adesso sì torniamo
Dammi
troppo tardi Ho già finito la colazione
ha fatto come vi ho detto grazie mille
tieni il tuo amore la tua ricompense e
mi ha dato 32 Wow
ora ho 45 dollari dove andiamo
proprio da questa parte della mappa che
non l'abbiamo ancora vista Ok bellissimo
esplorare questa città di Halloween
così prendiamo delle caramelle Qua c'è
una persona normale non c'è un mostro Ok
andiamo subito a suonare allora
campanello Ehi Sì
sbrigati dai
Ciao vado dall'altra parte
Uh che carino Un gatto no non è un gatto
è un pipistrello come ha fatto a vedere
un gatto Boh sembravo un gatto nero
volante
tantissimissimissima caramella vai Io li
ho zero ma perché ogni tanto spariscono
le caramelle non capisce velocemente
altrimenti vanno via no spariscono dal
mio inventario prima ne avevo quattro
cinque sei e adesso non si sente no
rubate tu puoi entrare guardavo Io le
vendo Seleziona tutto okay Uh $10,50 via
dolcetto scherzetto
vediamo
Ho trovato un gattino nero un gattino
nero mmm mmm mi sembra molto arrabbiato
con questo gattino nero Eh forse non
vuole fare amicizia con te Ah è un po'
scioccato oh oh oh Aiuto Sono stato
attaccato da un pipistrello ah ah così
impari a andare in giro con tutte quelle
caramelle No no le ho vendute
tutte scherzetto 10 caramelle Oh no ne
avevo lasciato due qua ma io sono tre Ne
ho presa io 12
Ah ma io ero già vendute eventi Ah ah ah
ah eccolo scambio di caramelle Vediamo
quanto mi do per 12 caramelle oh oh 51
dollari
Io voglio l'animale Voglio il gattino io
vi voglio trasformare in zucca Invece
secondo me si sta molto bene il costume
da zucca tondo vediamo un po' Quanto
costava il gattino
160 davvero
troppo tempo vediamo quanto costa la
zucca Ah potrei prendere la zucca felice
La zucca è cattiva come felice ci vuole
la zucca cattiva prendiamo la zucca
cattiva allora sì
ho un dollaro però hahaha questa è la
mia zucca cattiva Ehi E questa no però è
questa Come faccio a portarla con me
Ah devi andare in inventario e poi da lì
prendi il costume lo indossi Eccola qua
la mia zucca cattiva verrà sempre con me
Eh si muove in modo un po' strano
Vediamo se mi farà guadagnare più
caramello
sarebbe molto bello prendere anche
qualcosa per muoversi più velocemente
vediamo quanto costano costeranno poco
ma non ci sono più i fantasmi le case in
realtà Esatto Ogni volta ci danno le
caramelle perché sei fortunato Ah sì
dici Uffa ma questa era troppo questi
potremmo prendere lo skate solo 80
vediamo forse la mia zucca spaventeremo
mostri e quindi mi daranno solo
caramelle Adesso ci vediamo Ehi dolcetto
scherzetto Sì caramelle Uhm
Quanto costa la moto
tantissimo Infatti quanto tempo ci vorrà
per avercela dobbiamo completare delle
missioni Forse facciamo prima prima
delle caramelle
quando sono rimasto bloccato Mi dice il
ragnetto qui dov'è bloccato in un nodo
districalo per me posso pagarti oh oh oh
anch'io voglio fare una missione Dimmi
dov'è io farò la missione della strega
Allora vediamo
i gatti neri sono scappati Puoi trovarmi
per me posso darti un gatto se lo fai sì
niente Volevo un Gatto
accetto subito Devo trovare 6 gatti Ehi
ma questo non mi darà quindi nessuno
cioè no poi non posso prendere la moto
però voglio un gatto Merlino
Ma lo sai che ho fallito la missione del
ragno
impossibile districare il nodo No mi
dispiace per questo ragnetto cioè
ragnetto è gigante è un rognone Invece
qua Merlino mi dice puoi prendere di
nuovo con il Game pass della scopa
volante Sì ma costa 500 robot
e invece Vediamo cosa dice il mago Ciao
saggio puoi dare una mano Eh sì Google
tranquilla
Il mio equipaggio ha perso tre scope
rosse se le trovi ti ricompenseremo Uh
Sì ma io li avevo già visto qualcuna a
prendere prima devi devi andare a
cercare adesso Eh sì infatti non mi
ricordo dove erano Vabbè comunque ho
accettato la missione vediamo se ci sono
fuori Sì è meglio accettare le missioni
perché si fanno più soldi che stanno
volando per la città e ho perso mia
madre Ah pensavo che verso i pipistrelli
Ti prego Riportami da mia madre Ok
riportiamoti da tua mamma Stai trovando
un sacco di missioni missione batti Ah
batti è il pipistrello non avevo capito
ma penso di aver capito dov'è battiti
dove la mamma di battiti Ah no non era
qui dietro in mezzo alle case Comunque
io ho un animale che mi segue
tu hai la zucca io il pipistrello Sei
laggiù vero eh No sono in mezzo alle
case Questa è la miss No no sono due
giocatori Ehi voglio più in missione che
ho trovato un pipistrello Che carino
Adesso aiuto stavo volando per la città
ho perso mia madre ma quindi pipistrello
ha perso Insomma
allora io credo di averla vista però non
mi ricordo dov'era Ah mi sta seguendo Ma
che carino Oh forse l'ho trovata vai
sempre dritto in mezzo alle case vediamo
Vediamo se lei esattamente
in mezzo alle case
qua anch'io vedo qualcosa da dire
hai un gatto è un pipistrello Io ho
trovato un gatto con mia sorella quello
che cosa sono questi
io devo dare il gatto all'altra missione
ma non lo fa prendere Vabbè fa niente Ci
sei riuscito Quindi ricompensa missione
animali battiti Evviva sciogliendo il
nodo
non mi dire che ci sei riuscita Ah io
l'ho fallito Infatti
Uffa è facile facile facile da da
superare Va beh proverò un'altra volta
Adesso vediamo un'altra missione cioè
proviamo a completare qualche missione
tipo i gatti neri e la mamma di Betty
dibattiti
parla con il vicino un'altra missione è
successo anche quest'anno se Pulisci
tutta la carta ti pagherò cioè
quale carta per favore pulisci tutto Sì
ma con calma eh
devo raccogliere 15 pezzi di carta
Poverino questo deve essere molto
antipatico che gli hanno tirato la carta
igienica gli hanno lanciato la carta
igienica sulla casa
perché sono gli scherzi di Halloween no
vuol dire che lui non ha dato i dolcetti
Sì ho trovato qualcosa lì c'è un corpo
Ehi ma tu sei riuscita a trovare le
braccia dello spaventapassetti l'ho
trovato solo una ho trovato un gatto Uh
gattino
uno di 6 Ah devi raccogliere sei sì devi
mettere un po' a trovarli tutti sono
difficili queste missioni cioè Bisogna
trovare un sacco di cose ecco il nostro
gatto che carino
suoniamo un altro campanello
allontaniamoci per sicurezza Ah no
caramelle
Buti ho spaventato No per niente ehi
signora per favore aiutami Ti prego Ma
come un'altra missione e il mio cane è
corso su uno di questi brevi alberi
dietro di me Io sono troppo basso per
raggiungerlo per favore aiutami anche io
sono bassa quindi non so se riuscirò a
prenderlo
allora nel frattempo prendo un gatto
e poi devo prendere qualcuno che è
questo
fallito cane non ho trovato
gli alberi per trovare il cane
Credo di sì Finché non lo trovo Sei
sicuro che il tuo cane stai solo un
albero tu che cosa hai trovato il
cimitero Ecco il cane Poverino
Soprattutto se è pauroso Grazie signore
l'hai trovato Vabbè comunque sono una
femmina fantasma Evviva ho preso una
ricompensa Oh anch'io voglio vedere il
cimitero
eh Te lo dico Wow allora ancora più
interessante il cavaliere senza testa
sul cavallo dice Ciao potresti aiutarmi
ma il cavaliere senza testa da dove
parla
ci sono fantasmi che valgono per il
cimitero raccogli la loro anima per per
permettere loro di riposare in pace ma
tu hai paura dei fantasmi
è facile sempre facile almeno è solo qui
nel cimitero Anch'io voglio la festa dei
fantasmi intorno
Ehi ma se adesso mi dà 45 per questa
missione più 45 Sto a 90 la moto costa
107 160 E allora no quante ne devo fare
ancora di missioni Ecco il cavaliere
senza testa Ciao potresti aiutarmi Va
bene dai dai Qua dovrebbe essere più
facile trovarli Ma questo ma sono questi
fantasmi questi cosi luminosissimi Sono
tipo quelle create Eh sì bravo sto
raccogliendo l'anima dei fantasmi Wow
ritorno dal cavaliere senza testa
vediamo Oh sgancia i soldi
a me mancano due fantasmi Grazie
potranno riposare in pace ora Ah bene
ecco 45 dollari Uffa dove sono Eccone un
altro missione completata anche qua Ok
ragazzi se volete vedere continua a
questo gioco lasciate un bel mi piace se
volete vedere altri video di Halloween E
ora vi lasciamo qua Questo qua cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video eh Buona
visione Ciao